salut tout le monde est bienvenu pour
cette nouvelle vidéo alors favori on va
regarder une partie en direct
maxime contre magnus gros gros
affrontement beaucamp blitz et ses
partisans que 4,5 à leur arc classique
de magnus mais la pendule semble
déconner ouais ils ont mal appuyée bombe
sous le seul angle berlinois d'or est ce
que ça à faire la finale de la
berlinoise ou pas nous faire des photos
tu faire les photos derrière on va on va
rentrer dans la grandeur de la
berlinoise la femme voilée dans la
finale on dirait jeu des quatre tours un
crédit et 6 on va bouffer ses six des
prend des heures à me prendre et huit
compagnies pas on ne l'a pas dit mais on
est à louvain on voit la superbe salle
fab mais ok juste il ya un truc super
chaud en fait on n'a pas notifié mais
qu'est ce qu'ils firent le cercle ou
jpeg lors de deux coups en fait tu as je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé mais un
vaste jeu de la finale juste les normes
peuvent reprendre du chou il pas dû y
avoir il joue la même finale centre des
rockets et tu peux refuser je dois me 2
mais je pense qu'il va jusqu'à et des
quatre qui prend dame prend elle est
juste je vais tapert de foutus rock
était tranquille non j'ai pas du tout ça
dès jeudi concentrée regardant la caméra
[Musique]
du coup tu ne sais pas pourquoi mais je
sais pas ce que fait ce pour eux ça te
bats le fond à cette date ou we are est
fou et 7 thorens a été rajoutée pour
avoir mal branlé toi larry charles
foulard et flûte bon je sais pas a du
coup on fait damas de peut-être même
celui qui est des cartes je crois que
c'est pas de souci donc chez parce mais
suède arbres endémiques du coup tu
prends du fou tu prends du roi à je
prends du chou pas je pense me verse un
jeune expert d'essoufflement il a pris
on va voir blake lively
il faisait 5 mais du coup à ses
supérieurs étaient pas des rockets
peut-être flou aussi comme ça mais tu es
juste bien là non et camara jeu je
suppose sous sénart sur un mur de
carcasses de cette spectatrice à
l'ouvrier plainte à mais je crois que
choisit je pense à merville est ce que
cette histoire de port d'une finale
ce serait comme les français toujours
oui c'est la faute de la pendue quoi
peut-être c'est l'arbitré concentre tu
mixes de variantes qui perd quand je
tourne maintenant tu tombes dans l'autre
avec des cats qui ressemble beaucoup
mais bon juste bizarre je sais pas dur
expliqué 4 ok c'est logique le fc rac
mais bon ok on n'est pas forcément moins
bien avec les blancs non plus même si
lorsqu'on a une meilleure structure de
pions non les poubelles c7 c6 ça va là
en fait ok disons que déjà la bernoise
de base je crois que ça devrait me
prépare on sait toujours pas que mon
père par ce truc
si on enlève un de nos avantages qui est
le roi de perse au centre qui à part à
brooke est donc plus difficile de lier
les tours tout ça avant la super au
sahel se rassembler mais il le fait
parce qu'il le fait reculer derrière
d'affaires recettes mais on n'a pas pu
jouer sur ce manque de coordination des
noirs vous à passer à la meilleure
structure mais le problème c'est
toujours pareil faudrait bernoise par
rapport à l'espagnol de l'ordre des
changes ce qu'on a déjà mis le pied en
or 5
donc du coup les cases blanches mais
maîtrise moins bien ça laisse des trous
note en bas le fou qui passe dans le
monde tu vois il plutôt passif et
l'instant qu'on a gardé plus de
désavantages du truc sans les avantages
donc c'est ok je te défonce savoir se
jouer ok il va pas il veut pas non plus
la perdre
faut pas abuser je suis levée peut-être
avait dû verser 4 vers 3 vrf cinq noms
pour vale où j'allais à cinq ans pour
chaque poste ils rentrent au pays d'être
tranquille et 2 les deux idées à gauche
un coup à droite
bah du coup sûr cassin qui veut faire
quoi échanger une fois en d1 et
souhaitons b8 je sens bien leur vie
n'est peut-être carrier des huit aussi
un genre cavalia cinq tours prend d un
truc qu'on ait un qui a aidé 8 le
protège l'un ou l'autre de toute façon
tu as pas trop le choix
ouais non me désire échanger autour des
huit jeux c'est bon cavalier au tour à
tour manqué mais
on est dopé en rappel dans ce genre de
position sont invités avec des blancs ça
c'était bien je préfère 4 5t contente
problème c'est qu'ils étaient bloqués
donc tu manques de plan maintenant
manque de plan matt a plus de plan en
fait c'est fini j'ai pas ce que tu veux
bon ok d'être avec 4 1 points j'attache
g5 qui est potentiellement un court
l'autre peut te faire du quai 18 b6
torque pousser un peu je sais pas c'est
technique c'est vers le nord j'ai cinq
soirées camille père logique 1 pour
commencer c'est 5 bat g 100 g jour
logique à n'importe quel moment de la
partie les saints qui l'empêchent qui a
aidé quatre aussi au passage
non je n'avance pas de casse gens se
veut faire bref de rois de 3 jumelles et
oppose sa joie tu prends la case de 4 ou
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas pourquoi
notation c'est logique souvent comme
plan d'avancé le pion f comme ça d'une
case
et puis après on rêve de re 3 oui c'est
pas très compromettantes heureuse comme
ça doit se tenir sa femme voilée long
terme avec lui ce qui techniquement je
suis un toit c'est aujourd'hui la il
aime bien jouer f pas être défaitiste
bon bah défaitiste mais il ya des
positions je préfère avoir mes glisse
que ça devant aider
c'est pas faux c'est pas faux tu
préfères lui j'ai une petite grotte quoi
te dire tu comprends pas tu vois pas ce
que je dis même si je comprends pas tu
me dis c'est pas faux as tu t'es mis à
jour avec camelot hockey autant d'être
subtil il profite que la tour d'un sont
prises pour des grands vsat vous devez
changer rependu caillan des 8 10 autres
arbitres votre choix
il va te faire calisesi sa private
attaqué le 5 mai faire bref de rois de
trois protégés après ans on va monter
loin l es le roi quoi bref deux je monte
sonne la charge
tuer les petits bris de style au passage
est très stressé la demande s'il va te
dire x 2 qui est rejoint directement en
cavalier quel intérêt mais tata essayons
food essonne
vous pouvez aussi ce n'est cette pénible
façon de le fouiller
mais c'est rare ça n'en fait d'avoir le
fou qui fera qui passe b un à 2,6
une personne porteuse cheval ou de loin
at elle commencé par bsi s'en fait mal
mon concert de petits soucis en ce
qu'elle est à 5 le pion aux cinq
attaques et thématiques seront proposées
de 2 soit deux fois détroit et g5
mais ça c'est en fait il veut te dire le
pion te sens tu ne nous protégera pas
chute à moto son âge il voulait peut
être un acteur clé du khalife quatre
échecs comme un truc wade a trahi et 4,3
maintenant comment faire pour que tu
veux aussi faire crisser 600 d'ailleurs
tu peux de mon être quatre fois ci va
battre coup sur x 2 sur x 2 sur x 2
peut-être cavaliers d2 et après on fait
des trois cavaliers c'est un domaine en
savoie pour maxime tente pas mal de
pièges
il peut s'en sortir mais j'entends ça je
suis plus + 5 hier encore maintenant il
ya un petit moment avant ça se dégrade à
tes inquiétudes augmentent on degré de
plaider si tu donnes tu préfères une
petite échelle sur le côté les
thermomètres de pls
les thermomètres combien la fédé niveau
5 5e dom on a pas on n'a pas la pendule
mais bon j'ai l'impression que magnus
réfléchit plus que maxime
mais bon c'est pas du bullet non plus
brillé le temps mon époux a déjà fini
pas fléchir ses pas il s'en fiche une
fois donc et des deux trucs dont on
parlait qui db3 cas et c'est un je m'en
vais rentrer mon ferme et ont eu menaces
le pion g2a il faut pousser non j'ai
trois peut-être même givrage et trois
autres aux logiques wade 4 octobre g3
quand même un g3 pour consolider tout le
match on a réussi cavaliers 4
ouais t'as pas mal d'options là quand
même sûrement important ce moment là
d'autres cas le cadre se passe pas si
mal
le cas de l'ex tu menaces g5 à ces cinq
sur échec si tu prends ces cinq qui
menacera bessette
je sais pas j'aime bien manger 3 tout à
fait correct aussi des six mois il
anticipe un peu peut-être cac valeo 4 du
coït b6 protection c5 qui coûte le
stream
oui ça vaut maintenant il faut jouer un
coup la maxime quand même un seul set h4
non t'es complètement foutue up quoi bon
repas au final même pas trop pousser des
plantes partout il ya eu 4
maintenant c'est mon truc son attitude
dans son body language même skf 5 passes
et ses caisses blanches sont
complètement demain des noirs pas donc
il a un moment le roi peu con ça à fond
ces cinq projets 4 mais on était petits
on prend et trêve arrive angers 6 je
sais pas un coq long je sais pas assez
chaud la femme
ces choses je le montre les faire gilles
katz qui nous soit son idée c'était de
faire que les cinq échecs pourra devenir
veut devenir en d3 défend de
bronchiolite
pour les 4 es tu perdais quelqu'un donc
donc le kg catch comprend encore ni
l'ivcc la menace émanant de gagner un
des 5 à chaque coup tu vois un truc qui
se rajoutent ishiaku tfc 4
au kenya les coujoux un peu vite en
ratant cas et des cinq échecs peut aller
question f
si tu vends f3 il veut jouer sur le
clouage j'imagine
ouais bon reste à voir comment
précisément narrateur est ce qu'on peut
pas filer les cavales user justice
défendre notre peuple en enfer moto je
sais pas n'a pas dix mille caste si on
vend des trois caisses qui veut faire en
fait il veut prendre au g5 tout bêtement
non même pas on reprend les ducs à
manier la sphère c4 séquelles d'une
pièce on va le faire ok évoluent quelqus
tu rawalpindi wifi cas efficace nous
souhaitons vous faire acheter à tâtons
férois b5 et on se bat non quand même ce
qu'elle puis on est passé des noirs un
jour à sa non défendra donc vous êtes en
retard chronique derrière parti ne
m'intéresse pas ne pas connaître
nous avons quatre ans il faut alliant et
fuites n'ont donc et maxime en fait ils
poussent à fond il est un danger il y
avait ceux ci sont pourtant une barrière
une barrière de corail quoi vous le
corps a ouais c'était pas mal joué ça h
4 h 5 g 5 v6 palestine et était obligé
de prendre l'option de soissons on
pousse mais le truc c'est que le
cavalier ce qu'il est vraiment plus fort
que le pion h
bon ça te donne notre lit d'un autre
point qui peut te faire des échecs la
légende des cinq sessions éventuellement
si tu défends c'est si tu veux ramener
le roi que pour la défense ou mais
plutôt à des cours d'attentats près
inquiet peut-être hindou si on fait h 7
on pourra plus en bout par contre si ce
qu'il fait ça l'est déjà
il revient c'est horrible et
insupportable et du coup on s'est hissé
de finale deux pions mais où le mec à
lecavalier pedone des échecs et où il a
des coûts d'attentes et en plus au qe2
donne des coups de tentes mais d'un
autre côté on peut peut-être une forme
étrange non wen ont peut-être filiales
et croît de 4 5 3 700 km et je croyais
qu'à trois ou quatre têtes 3 3 3 3 et 3
es tu vois je file vers le canal en fête
mais là maintenant je vais est encore
bon j'avais b5 aussi rapide ouais
peut-être ça permet en tous les cas si
tu as red star vous avec un pion un dom
tu défendes un pack ouais c'est horrible
bah c'est horrible ce mauvais sûr on
apprend ensuite à 2,3 g 8 a ramé
d'am-dam et c'est fini non ma belle
partie fab
ouais bah belle partie monde a perdu un
oeil comme un bon technique de cartes
non à bientôt les mecs
ciao